Arnett sunglasses. Remember those sunglasses dude,
I wore our nets and I swear to God when I put our net or our MP,
some would call them RNs because they thought it was like foreign.
And even if it is our needs, it's not. It's our nets in America.
That's how we're doing it. And I had these green Arnett sunglasses, bro.
You think I don't have the feeling I have right now.
I can nostalgically feel the feeling of having the Arnett sunglasses on.
I felt like I felt, I felt, you know what? I felt like,
That's how I felt. They'd be like, Chris, are you going to go to,
are you going to go get a bagel with us? And I'd be like, yeah.
Sorry, you guys, I have English class.
And I put on my sunglasses dude, they were green and they were a little shiny.
And then my uncle gave me a little shot for wearing them. And I was like,
I'm about one way. I'm all that long. You know that much anymore. Oh,
post Malone has a deal with our net. Jesus, they're still around,
but they don't look like they used to. I mean, they used to look sick in 1998.
You can. I don't think you can wear Arnet, sunglasses,
those kinds without putting gel in your hair. For real dude,
Asians had five or six Arnett, sunglasses.
You weren't technically Asian.
If you didn't have all a bunch of Arnett sunglasses,
and then also drove a Acura Integra for real.
And also Asians either have a picture of themselves
on the dash hanging from the, uh, what do you call it? The rear view mirror,
not the rear view mirror or they have a picture of them and their car in their
wallet. That's how it was in the nineties either. Or if you didn't, you weren't,
you were, you were like secretly, Indiana. You know what I mean?
I know that's over there, but like you were not, you were not Korean.
Like there's no way Korean either have a picture of them on their rear view
mirror in their car or a picture of them
and their car in their wallet. And that's that? That's that?
And I don't make these rules, dude. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Uh,
our nets. Yeah, our nets. Um, yeah, they were the.
I had the feeling of it. Sometimes you can feel that used to happen. I had to,
I used to, I don't wear cologne. You know that because there's no Kirk cologne.
There's just perfume.
And if you put on and if you're a man and you put on cologne, congratulations,
you're a female that put on perfume and that's all good. We're not judging,
but turn around. Let's go on a date, dude. That's all good. Hey bro,
you wore cologne. All good. What are you doing later?
It's all good. And I don't and I don't judge you,
but would you like to go to a movie sometime?
Hey, Hey guy, or.
Good spray what you want on your neck?
My only question is, would you like to go to a matinee sometime
because there's no, because it's more fume and I'll be inside you later,
maybe in a few dates. Uh, so, so yeah, so I,
I used to, when I was a kid, you know,
I would still try and spray cologne. I'd try, you know, I figure myself out.
I had the Arnett sunglasses and I had two colognes that were the.
I tried three cold water cologne. Didn't really like it.
Then I tried Fahrenheit that, every time I smell it now,
even still that sends me back, dude, I love Fahrenheit. That smell is the.
But only because it's nostalgic and that there was an old
one that I don't think is around anymore. It might be, but it was called Pocco.
And I got that because my friend, Brendan goodie got it. And he was like,
it's the? And he was kind of good with chick. So I was like, I'll get Pocco
girls will be slipping and falling all over the place. All need to get up.
I I'll get Pocco. I'm taller than Brendan. My them Brandon, my,
my, my shoulders. They, you know,
they travel out the distance and Brandon's were way closer to his ears.
Therefore I'll have to,
I'll have to get Pako at target because I'm also going to have to pick up some
towels for the girls in a sand. Um,
so I got Pocco and he was still better with chicks, but, um, uh,
I got Pako and then I got, uh, and then I got, uh,
and I got Fahrenheit and those were the and cold water. Cool water.
Cool water is what it was not cold water.
That's that's that's a street in the Valley. Cool. Water, cool water. Cause uh,
Snoop used to, you used to rap about that. Um,
anyway, and then, and then I was like, what the am I doing, dude?
You know, you gotta figure out who you, who you are, you really do. And uh,
and you gotta make some mistakes and that's okay.
That's how you figure out who you are and you gotta keep making mistakes too.
You can't, you know,
I think changing your mind is a good thing for sure. For sure.
And I made a mistake with Pocco and I made a mistake with, you know,
Fahrenheit still smells good, but I made a mistake, um,
because he can't put cologne on if you're just, you know, you can,
but it's perfume and you're a woman and it's all good. And it's all good. Um,
so yeah, so our net sunglasses, I'd love to see some now,
just some new Arnett sunglasses. I've never, I haven't seen him in a long time,
but it doesn't really matter that much. Uh, by the way,
you can probably get them. I wonder if they had a much sunglass hut.
I thought it was sunglasses had, I didn't see that. What does this say?
Sunglasses? I thought it was sunglasses hot,
but it's sunglass hot and it should be,
it should be, it should be sunglasses hot. I figured that out.
I figured that out. So yeah. You know, and that's it.
My girl was laughing at me cause she was like, it's sunglass,
it's sunglass hut. And I was like, well, it shouldn't be, and it shouldn't be,
it should be sunglasses hut because it's not a hut made out of sunglasses.
That would be sunglass hut. That would be sunglass hut,
mud hut, right? Mud, mud hut.
What other kind of HUD is there? I don't know if there's only a mud hut,
straw hut, sunglass hut.
I'm going to go into a sunglass hut and be like, Hey, what's the deal?
You guys lie, dude. W w w w w what? These walls
it sunglasses hut. Because there are sunglasses in the hut. It's also not a hut.
They should call it sunglasses mall room,
sunglasses store. It's a sunglasses store. Dude.
Sunglass hut, dude. Don't try and be cute with me.
You think when I go to Denny's I get, I,
I look at the waiter in the eyes and I say, I'll take the moons over my hammy,
eat my.
No way would I ever say that dude eat my whole,
dude. I say, I want this one. If that's what I want.
And hopefully the waiter's not blind because I'm not getting it. If she is, Oh,
well, what is that, sir? I'm blind. Oh, give me a Turkey sandwich for sake,
dude. I'm going to get the two cam.
No dude. Denny's now look,
I'm a big fan of Denny's you know that? Cause I hand out.
So I hand out Gris names all day long, right?
I hand out to grand stamps to Mark Walberg in my head.
I've got them stored in case I'm on transformers nine,
but dude, you know like
Denny's are you going to make me say moons over my hammy?
That's the thing about Denny's is, you know, there's some,
either guy in a borderlands,
like there were think of something cute marketing or they're like,
let's with everyone and make them have to say moons over my hammy
or even knows what moons over Miami moon over Miami. What is it?
It was that like a song or something moon over Miami. That sounds like some,
Frank Sinatra would sing. And also everyone else would sing too.
Like there would be the Dean Martin version of the Frank Sinatra version,
the Sammy Davis Jr version.
And then the other guys that look like just date with a date,
rape looking one on the rat pack moon over Miami and
your eye please. Oh, it's talking about eyes in those old songs.
What is it? Moon Ray. What's a song. Ray. Charles. See,
there you go. Moon. Over my enemy.
They're such a chauvinistically song too. No doubt. Secretly. Yeah.
Moon over Miami
women. Don't count Brown. [inaudible]
Hey there you shut up.
God that moon over my army in the Moonlight.
I can tell you that you're less than me.